[Music]
okay gamers
the day has come this is the big one
grand theft
auto 5.
the game was just released i have not
checked the internet
but my assumption
is that sales are almost non-existent
because everyone's waiting to hear my
review
i'm joined now by
my companion aaron blair hello sir you
are the digital nerd who helps me the uh
sancho panza to my digital quixote i
prefer web producer but that's fine you
play different people in this game and
there's a guy named franklin trevor is
like a meth tweaker out kind of near the
salton sea the alamo c when we start
here we're gonna play michael all right
that's me in my house right yeah all
right so here there's a car let's walk
towards the car yeah now a big thing
obviously in grand theft auto is driving
that's the big thing
yep and there you go yep yep okay
how do i back up uh left trigger all
right so now let's just kind of drive
around get a feel for it
it was fantastic
this is actually how i commute to work
you can also steal any car if you see a
car you like you can jump out and then
just steal it
oops
oh nice yup
oh nice all right now get yellow to get
his car
nice there you go little mini cooper
[Laughter]
oh there's your phone so press green to
answer it hey jim
i'm going for a drink dad [ __ ] i mean
our boat going down the western highway
it's it's been stolen what
the yacht's been stolen your son tried
to sell your yacht without you knowing
this happens air all the time and my son
tried to sell my yacht right without me
knowing it yeah and this the yacht got
stolen and now it's going down the
highway there's your boat go ahead go
left there's your boat just pull up
right behind the boat and franklin's
gonna jump onto the boat try not to hit
the thing oh god what okay back up i'm
going i'm going up
oh my god they're not letting me get in
there oh he fell off the duck
near him again all right franklin died i
don't you know what i've known franklin
in eight minutes
boo hoo franklin died yeah here you go
all right just go controller's really
sweaty sorry
oh my god this is so
take a left i'm doing it you sweat it up
the controller
i know i i get nervous my hands sweat
when i get nervous yeah get him right
behind the boat so it's trying to crash
into his boat though try not to crash
into the boat go go go go go go go go
oh my god
just keep going straight you're doing
good now what we got to shoot this guy
now tell me how to do that we're gonna
have to press this button you do it lean
over and do what you got to do use the
right stick
to kind of aim at him i'll just get her
i'll do it you do it you drive though do
it to the right
got away
that's me seven times a day in my car
so all right now who are these guys so
these guys they live up near the alamo
sea alamo c yeah you take the map i'll
drive all right
sorry it's sweaty we're gonna kill a
bunch of players so here's the thing
you seriously have to wear gloves next
time we do this
this thing is soaking wet it makes you
really nervous what idiot in this game
would ride without a seat belt in the
back seat of an open car
he's got a life expectancy of eight
seconds
wait does this mean i don't have to come
see the bikers okay so now we're chasing
these bikers yeah i'll drive so you want
to hit this yeah just that top button
there
yeah
got him got him got him sweet
i'm gonna lead us back now
no no no no no no which way supposed to
go no it's okay this thing always writes
itself
we lost wade though we lost the guy in
the back who needs wade has he
contributed anything so far
why do we need wade i think we need him
i mean he's a friend of ours
why did we need wade
that guy did absolutely wade was
abandoned admission should not be
aborted because we lost he's a friend of
ours we have to stick together truthless
meth tweaker that's a flaw in the game
i'm saying it right now the loss of wade
was an
improvement it's the efficiency of our
squad
how do we get to the strip club we just
have to turn it off i gotta get to the
strip club
get out of my way
[Applause]
[Music]
this is my strip club exit which is my
place
okay here i come
here
[Applause]
nice this is a nice one what is the girl
doing why is she bopping around like
that she's doing like cable exercises we
had to turn off the music for licensing
purposes
i see
so she's dancing to music
it just looks like she's having some
sort of like insulin shock seizure
let's go see if we get a private dance
like you want a private dance yes yes
i'm so wet right now
oh it's raining
is that what she meant we can touch her
and flirt with her oh wait no don't do
it though okay look out yeah
hey cheats marin
and then you can press this button to
flirt with her please just don't tell me
your life story
that's flirting
guy avoiding a bouncer at a strip club
that's the game right now he's back this
will teach you to get handsy
no
right under my direction
[Laughter]
you know what my erection broke my fall
to the spring
knocked him right back up to his seat
look how awkward this is to just stand
with this guy look at this this is so
great best part of the game
i'm gonna go back in
there's no way you're getting back in
here you're like fight
yeah you guys
you want to hit this point
you want to pull out a gun yeah
oh we got killed well what what what
they killed as soon as we pulled out a
gun they shot us wait i just got shot
and i went to the hospital yeah and
whenever you die you wake up in the
hospital you know what's nice
this is sort of a pro obamacare
he's got full coverage
look at it he got shot he went to the
crappiest looking hospital in the world
and within an hour he's running
there's this big problem right
[Laughter]
sorry gotta get to the strip club
where everybody knows your name
this is his cheers
thanks i was killed here an hour ago
two girls nice
same thing what would you like to do to
us
i don't know
uncross your eyes
no
no
all right we've now gotten into a
chopper all right let's go in a chopper
that fires missiles
kick me out of a strip club i come back
with a missile firing chuck
there it is where it's the strip club
that's the strip club
yeah
what happened
no
no i have a strip club in my sights
i've got to those girls laughed at me
on the left yes i see it yeah fire down
on it
yeah
oh no you're going to rip
it
oh there we go all right we're locked on
we're locked onto that guy to the
bouncer we've locked onto it i have
brought a missile firing chopper back to
the strip club the bouncer sees me
i'm locked on
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
what bouncer has a grenade
bouncer is prepared for a helicopter
attack
conan give us your rating of grand theft
auto 5. okay here's my rating uh if
punching a random pedestrian in the face
and stealing their ford explorer to
commit crimes is good uh and taking a
helicopter that you hijacked that can
fire missiles and using it to destroy a
strip club because they tossed you out
is bad
i would give this a rating of
driving through a meth village
killing motorcycle gangs for no reason
that's my rating
awesome
[Music]